this is the biggest trap for people in
depression just like we have physical
immune systems we have psychological
immune systems but much like our
physical immune system the greater the
harm the longer it takes expecting the
same quick turnaround to meaning and
growth as a Fool's errand you have to
give your psychological immune system
sometime and you have to be really
patient with yourself when we're falling
physically or metaphorically time slows
down depression is like the swamp and it
becomes all-consuming and it just feels
like it is going to be forever and that
is just your brain changing its
perception of time and there's not much
that you can do to speed it up but if
you know that if you have just the
littlest bit of consolation that hey
like even though this feels like forever
now when I look back on this period
five years from now 10 years from now 20
years from now it's not going to feel so
long holding on to that little bit of
Hope can go such a long way